we're told that f of x is equal to one
over the square root of x plus one and
what we want to figure out is what is
the second degree maclaurin polynomial
of f and like always pause this video
and see if you could have a go at it
so let's remind ourselves what a
maclaurin polynomial is a maclaurin
polynomial is just a taylor polynomial
centered at zero so the form of this
second degree maclaurin polynomial and
we just have to find this maclaurin
expansion until our second degree term
it's going to look like this
so p of x i'm using p for a polynomial
it's going to be our f of 0
plus
we we could view that as f of 0 times x
to the 0 power well that's just f of 0 f
0 plus
f prime
of 0
x
plus
f prime prime of 0 divided by we could
think of it as 2 factorial but it's
really just 2. we could think of this
dividing by 1 factorial which is just 1.
this dividing by 0 factorial but that's
just 1 again so we have f prime prime of
0 the second derivative evaluated 0
divided by 2
x squared now if we wanted a higher
degree we could keep on going but
remember they're just asking us for the
second degree so this is the form that
we're going to need we're going to have
these three terms so let's see if we can
evaluate these
let's see if we can evaluate the
function and its derivatives at 0. so f
of 0
f of 0 is equal to 1 over the square
root of 0 plus 1. well that's 1 over the
square root of 1 the principal root of 1
which is positive 1 so that's just going
to be equal to 1. so that right over
there is equal to 1.
now let's evaluate
f prime of x and then i'll evaluate f
prime of 0.
f prime of x is equal to well 1 over the
square root of x plus 1 this is the same
thing as x plus one let me write it this
way
this is the same thing as
let me actually let me write it down
this way
f of x another way of writing f of x is
this is the same thing as x plus 1
to the negative one-half
and so if i'm thinking the first
derivative of f
well i could use the chain rule here the
derivative of x plus 1 with respect to x
well that's just going to be 1 and then
i'll take the derivative of this whole
thing with respect to x plus 1 and i'll
just use the power rule there so it's
going to be negative 1 half
times x plus 1 to the and i decrement
the exponent negative
3 halves
and so the first derivative evaluated at
zero is just negative one half times if
this is zero zero plus one is just one
one to the negative three halves
one to the negative
three half power well that's just going
to be one so this whole thing f prime of
zero is just negative one half
so that is
this right over here is negative one
half
and now let's figure out the second
derivative
all right i'll do this let me do this in
this
green color
so the second derivative
with respect to x
well i do the same thing again the
derivative of x plus one with respect to
x is just one so i just have to take the
derivative of the whole thing with
respect to x plus 1. so i take my
exponent bring it out front negative 3
halves times one-half times negative
one-half is going to be positive
three-fourths
times x plus one
and then i decrement the exponent here
by one or by two halves so it's going to
be negative
five halves and so the second derivative
evaluated at zero
well if this is equal to zero you're
gonna have one to the negative five
halves which is just one times
three-fourths is going to be
three-fourths
so
this part right over here is
three-fourths and so you're gonna have
three-fourths divided by two
three-fourths divided by two is
three-eighths
so our taylor or actually our maclaurin
polynomial our second degree maclaurin
polynomial p of x
is going to be equal to and i'll do it
in the same colors it's going to be
equal to 1
plus
or maybe i'll just write it as negative
minus one half
minus
one half x
plus
3 8 x squared
3 8
x squared and we
are done there you have we have our
second degree maclaurin polynomial of f
which is could be used to provide an
approximation for our function
especially as we as especially for x's
near zero